hello welcome to this video it's Donny
tough one of my frequent opponent
recently enough frequent nah but I had
him just a bit earlier three out of
three against them so let's continue
that streak previewing that is kind of
dicey
where is taking a long time for those
early moves yeah here d 6 is not
entirely satisfactory I have to switch
to this kind of setup okay let's
surprise that you allowed the a4 move
okay so it tries to play with 92 m and
then you form of course can try that so
I'm going here on f3 I play c5 ok now
let's go see five now interesting
question trading the nights here or not
mmm I'd sure if this is an idea or not
and 94 that was where that was the thing
that I wasn't sure
I can't take on de 495 said something it
wasn't that doesn't really fit within my
earlier moves but hmm maybe you can go
see fine now oh ah ok so I found a way
to lose a game against him let's blunder
the exchange shoot ok well it's still
not it's still not totally easy it is I
blundering a for now you didn't take it
that's good news
I don't get it what is he doing it no
I'm this pawn up here it's not so easy
anyway it's going to look a 4 then or
what
hmm
how do i play him quince to keeping the
Queen's on notice the interesting
question him night and queen you
sometimes can get tricky counterplay
alice is good though I mean okay for you
got Queenie one that took her took ages
to understand that ok so now i have to
trade unfortunately check check
mmm can go here and here and this is a
good F form takes takes a three hmm I
don't know what is the best way can also
come around him jun c6 does it try a
form why am I even thinking here check
probably just wants to shoot for time
win here time warning check
no I don't know check
I mean that does not work but not quite
sure why he ever allowed me to do that
well maybe it does work check
unfortunately protected I really showed
me in a game right by playing all those
moves so quickly okay so black as I lost
it to twist off yeah unfortunately
losing whatever I do even here Jack
cannot keep that perhaps unfortunately
really just losing even then I mean he
could have played efforts of course is
better but I even have some chances
maybe I should just keep the pawns back
then but it was difficult because of
three minutes against one something like
age six or so just to stay and see how
he tries to win that position probably
would have been interesting yeah I was
just idiotic Lee this is just this is
just just totally totally wrong this
blundering stuff yeah it's just a pretty
normal position I mean yeah and normal
what what what is normal here but if I
don't blunder blunder material we just
play a game there I can know the thing
is ok this is already not grade be hard
cause I had don't have d5 so um I can
play whatever this or whoop dat i don't
know it's not a not a big deal the
interesting thing is that both sides him
have some questions to answer with with
regards to the pawn structure yeah why
Posey foil take on d4 and play Knight c5
that is not clear that's good you know
black on the other hand also doesn't
have any clear porn pushes I wanted to
change the position into an IQ p
position which wouldn't be bad after
straight but I just blundered into this
and here should avoid to lose the a pawn
then dead least gets I mean yeah okay he
has to play some some good moves maybe
the way I'm the way it turned out with
him getting the a porn he could have
taken a 4 let's of course better but he
was keen on playing instantly long time
but it is so bad yeah you can even play
that rubbish and still win yeah I mean
sorry but why not just take here I mean
you can can just take the point that was
the big problem with the with that rugby
a move and just give a gave away the
apron which she did not take but it is
so bad white can can play all that and
still win blundering a whole exchanges
too much okay thanks for watching